yeah you can buy looks i'll tell you
that you know all this surgery stuff you
know a lot of times because he's had it
done chappelle
because i got it
because i don't know
how many procedures including the skin
you're we're talking several procedures
excuse me hold on excuse me no excuse me
two hair plants sure two or three here
one hair transplant had two i swear on
my life i haven't one hair he had one he
had the lids done he had the skin
excuse me no i didn't have skin dressing
i had my oh yes
i had my lids done and by the way i
asked a bunch of questions i was
fascinated about how many people get
work done i was just fascinated with the
process i got to know the plastic
surgeon yeah but but
i've never had when you have a when
somebody goes
and they burn it off with with i with uh
dry ice
that's not a procedure that's just 100
of this
it's i if you have a sunspot you have to
burn off that that part so you don't get
skin cancer that's all you're doing yeah
sure so you get on your arms how long it
takes
to do it's that fast but then you did
your arms
kylie's like me too yeah me too three
minutes three minutes it's not even like
botox yeah in and out that's not a
procedure i've never had bones for an
hour guaranteed guarantee you're in
there overnight no no it's like this
look
now go to your arms now go to your arms
now go to your arms yep keep going keep
going
keep going yeah that one's a little
longer that counts as a procedure
dude you've had four i'm having
i have i have skin cancer
you know i'm not i don't but you that's
a medical procedure no you did because
you don't like the spots on your face
it's a medical procedure yeah it's like
people getting rid of freckles i'm with
you dude
it's
it's sunspots that's not a procedure you
can't call it that counts okay doesn't
count i had my lids down three i had two
plastic surgery things like my lids and
my hair transplant lids is the biggest
thing you've done but the hair
transplant didn't take i don't know if
you know that well that you did in the
night well i had bad hair for it so what
what the guy said is he goes your your
scalp's very tight and you don't have
good hair for this and you still went
through it so it didn't really it didn't
really take so yeah do you have that
scar like rogan yeah you do no you don't
let me see
yeah
you can't see it but it's it goes like
oh yeah if you shave your head
completely you'd see it out of the way
rogan's is lower i thought i thought
something happened to me yeah he's had
like three but now now i have they take
they take uh one follicle at a time yeah
there's no scar now yeah no there's
nothing kelly's had uh a few done his is
really good yeah
but there's nothing to do about that
yeah
no you can
but i think it's it takes better when
you do it younger that's why theo does
it yeah he's not that young he's a nice
looking guy
yeah machine on camera
why not machine gun's from colorado yeah
no yeah he's from ohio he's not though
born and raised in colorado two's 14 and
moved to ohio when he's 14. so he's a
white boy
yeah but he's from colorado we claim him
yeah jer pivens is fantastic too
wow and jamie foxx
yeah i don't see why you wouldn't have
been the best of all yeah
i'm kidding
play george costanza on seinfeld did our
boy our boy logan paul looks like he's
uh he's is he here yeah he's he's losing
his hair a little bit no yes he is i
noticed that actually a while back oh
the forehead area for sure he does do
that thing where yeah he does like that
he's recovering i can see that it's okay
he'll get it done too he's so rich too
yeah we have that money i don't i don't
know why you wouldn't do it i don't ever
i don't know why everybody would crazy
crazy expensive isn't it no it's like 10
years dude i'm still holding out on on
tr
10 grand for like to change your life
like that yeah to have good hair
[ __ ] if you're not on trt and getting
your hair done i don't know what you're
doing
stevie stevie do you not want to
optimize
do that would be the best person
possible stevie go to the auto gym